[Music]
so today we're getting transformed into
our hero musicians I'm gonna try a look
inspired by Amy Winehouse because I love
her mmm you could hear it in her music
that she was so honest and that she was
being herself with every lyric that she
wrote and every song that she put out
some of her songs were uplifting some of
her songs were sad but that was the
reality of her Amy Winehouse was so
compelling in part because she was able
to somehow combine a certain type of
confident imperfection with a very
humble virtuosity today I'm being
transformed into John Lennon so John
Lennon is probably the only person who
gives me the chills every time I hear
any of his songs
my dad just played him over and over and
over again it's like a very nostalgic
emotional connection I have with Lennon
that I don't have with any other artist
I think Lennon's longevity in the public
imagination and in our listening
practices has a lot to do with the style
of the songwriting that he was
constantly innovating and attempting to
develop new means for us to actually
understand the world around us
today I'm gonna be dressed in a Pharrell
inspired look he's pretty much one of
the greatest humans to ever walk there
Pharrell was I feel like the first
outlet to like let me be able to be
myself
these are credible so in particular in
the hip-hop genre there's a certain
perceived notion or stereotype of black
masculinity is always aggressive and
there are many many different ways in
which hip-hop musicians have refused
those types of labels and Pharrell is
one of those people I'm a little worried
about what I'm gonna look like I mean
I'm down to try it out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the biggest thing I think is the hair
obviously she has this huge beehive and
so I'm kind of on the fence of how it's
gonna look on me every time I saw a real
I just felt like I was looking at like
that cool uncle I always wanted to have
felt like when I first put the jacket on
like that was the foundation when a hat
came out you know that's when it was
just like that's what it was done I
think that I sometimes accidentally
dress like Lennon so yeah I would rock
that look his son is in particular but
the middle part you know um it's not in
right now he pulled it off I'm not very
used to wearing bright lip colors so
this is something that's definitely very
weird for me when we brought the wig
over I was like that is not going to fit
on my head we definitely tried and we
got it on it's on my head I hope it's
gonna look cool I hope I do him some
kind of justice and and I hope my dad
sees this and he and he's happy with it
[Music]
lying around with flower petals being
thrown at my face what a dream I
definitely think that the aesthetic
today I think I think Pharrell approves
of this when speaking about Pharrell I
don't even know if it's like dance
it's like groove you find the beat and
you ride it and then you're just like
yeah yeah this is it
[Music]
I don't know how it's gonna look I don't
know how I did internally I feel so shy
because I'm not used to just like doing
that because I listen to some of her
music and just like try to appreciate
who she was and the way that the music
always made me feel honestly I had a lot
of fun so I'm hoping that that's
conveyed through the video I'm excited
to see it but only time will tell
[Music]
I didn't even know that this data reveal
was part of this video so this is kind
of exciting but I'm a little bit nervous
too because I've got big shoes to fill
I'm excited to see how it turned out it
was it was some really cool stuff
happening you know the dance moves was
there the vibes were there the outfit
was there you know so I'm excited about
it I'm excited but I also hope I don't
look crazy I really wanted this to be
something that honored her and was kind
of a beautiful appreciation of what I
appreciate about her so I hope it comes
off that way yeah all right I'm gonna
press play
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] [ __ ] cool I look like a stoned
lesbian genre and
[Music]
[ __ ] Elana love it that looked heaps
better than I imagined
I am a little bit cool I didn't know
that so I'm really excited for my dad to
see this now I was a little bit nervous
particularly you know like the five
o'clock shadow thing had me a little bit
like yeah but it works
[Music]
[Music]
I like that I like that so one of those
things I almost want to watch again I
think sometimes it's like hard to watch
yourself you know cause like where we
are our big biggest critic it didn't
feel forced like it just felt like it
was you know and it just like exude it
kind of like Pharrell's charisma you
know it's just it's there you don't know
what it is but it's something I think I
did injustice and it was it was well
executed well shot and it was just put
together very tastefully we were Oh
we let the hair is so ratty though it's
a soda
you took my heart and me colder
[Music]
my soul and Chava it looks like this is
my actual style you know like if I was
walking around I wouldn't be comfortable
with it but the way that I look I look
so comfortable with it honestly just
props Amy Winehouse for owning her style
you know just being herself and not
being afraid of what people are gonna
think or say about it I'm really glad
that I don't look as awkward as I felt
I'm still not doing that hair every
[ __ ] end I'm never doing that again
the ways in which people actually engage
the music is suggestive than of how they
engage with the musicians so music is a
way in which people are often connected
to the world around them and these
musicians that become the conduit for
our connections they become the ways in
which we can imagine ourselves thinking
differently or living differently or
being differently in the world and so
people quite often have a very
significant attachment to the musicians
that they listen to and whom they
idolize
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh